they'll face aaron nola noah making his
13th start this year four and four 11
and seven lifetime against the atlanta
braves yeah it's been difficult for him
recently he got the win as last time out
philly scored 17 runs in that ball game
but he got the win
checked his swing again that time he
wins as joe west
[Applause]
out to center field
herrera is there he moves back a couple
steps
and he makes the catch for the second
out
curveball trying to back foot it and he
walks him so a two out walk now that
brings the dangerous austin riley to the
plate
swing and a shot hammered toward the gap
in right center that ball is going to
get down for a base hit ozzy's flying
around second he's coming to third he's
coming home there'll be no throw on
austin reilly with two outs has given
atlanta a one-nothing lead on a ringing
two-strike double with two outs
basketball hit back toward the middle
caught by gene segura
see drew smiley's numbers nine starts on
the year two and three with a 598 we've
talked about the home run ball so
you know look for him he's got a lead
look for him to uh
correct some of that tonight he's
obviously aware of it i know he's been
working on it so looking to close the
door the 2-2 on the way hit in the air
out towards right field acuna goes back
now comes in and makes a chest high
catch for out number one here in the
bottom of the first inning he'll try
again
broken back back to the mound smiley to
second for one ozzy flips to first and
in time a double play
goes into his wind up and here's the
three two on the way
that is ripped out to right field at a
base hit deposited a fastball out in the
right now bryce harper bobbles it
and staying put at first base will be
almonte
curveball lined out toward left field
mccutcheon is out there and he makes the
catch going back to first almante
swing
foul tip hung on to by real muto second
strikeout
we film another change up to get him two
outs of the man at first nola ready
here's the pitch
a mess he struck him out
[Applause]
it's sharply but right into the shift
riley is in shallow right field
on the ground riley smothers scrambles
to his feet and a tag applied at first
good play by freddie freeman
mccutchen it's the first pitch he sees
at the deep left center field going back
towards the gap and running it down as
abraham amante ronald acuna leads it off
for the braves and that should make
braves fans very happy because in his
career he has done very well versus erin
nola first pitch here in the third
inning
fastball is smashed deep down the left
field line towards the pole that is a
home run out of ronald acuna
murano brings the fire power to philly
and it's two nothing atlanta here in the
top of the third inning 99th career
homer 18th this year tying him with
vladimir guerrero jr
little pitch coming
ground ball toward the shift off the
glove and swanson into shallow center
field great base running by baum he just
keeps on going and now first and third
with nobody out and here is aaron noah
with four sacrifices so far this year
that one's funded to the right here
comes baum and smiley will take it and
throw out nola that worked beautifully
for the phils
it's a 2-1 ball game all right so runner
in third and two outs see if gene can
get that run home tied this game up
wow
that's about it second walk for segura
awesome
popped up
sander of the diamond who wants it in
foul ground freddy freeman is there and
it almost popped out of his glove
but he hangs on to make the play
ground ball softly to short terrais
charges gotta hurry and does
the wind-up and nola's two-strike offer
ground ball right side sharply hit but
to his left segura gobbles it up throws
on first amante hustling down the line
really is just out william contreras
will do his best to get on base here and
avoid the one two three inning and his
61st pitch
is swung on it high in the air toward
right center field herrera turns and
watches that ball sail into the stands
contreras on the first pitch has hit his
sixth homer and the braves get that run
right back
two solo homers for atlanta
braves lead at 3-1 here in the fourth
but center cut man he didn't miss it
and bryce harper will lead off here
against drew smiley
3-0 and he blasts this one deep right
center field and that one is gone
how about that for timing wow
a 3-0 pitch and he whacks it out to
right center field and it got out in a
hurry his eighth home run of the season
and just like that it's a one-run game
again 3-2
that ball was just flat out golden the
0-2 pitch
breaking ball fly ball headed toward the
right field corner acuna checks the
scoreboard and somehow made the play
he turned the wrong way and reached up
at the last instant and hauled it in
swank in a drive hit to left did he get
it high enough no but it's going to die
at the base of the wall
mccutcheon over picks it up quickly but
not before acuna stands at second
freddy's flight out struck out
breaking ball hammered up the middle of
base hit acuna broke back towards second
the ball gets by herrera
and acognia will score freeman to second
and the braves get a gift it's a 4-2
atlanta lead
curveball bounce toward third should be
two there's one over to first in time a
fastball from gene segora all right well
the williams family came to watch their
son
brother friends bat
in his major league debut and here is
luke williams williams had a heck of a
last couple months joe's bought buns
toward third how about that for a
beautiful bun and it goes right on by
freddie freeman
and it's
stopped by the
tri-vision but williams is speeding a
third a bunt single for his first major
league hit hopefully the fields can get
this run home gene segura has walked
twice
that one's out toward left center field
on the run is heredia he's not going to
get it it's going to go off the base of
the wall on one hop williams will score
sigour to second rbi double it's back to
a one-run game 4-3 ball game braves lead
it jt rio muto who has grounded out and
walked
out toward right field that's well hit
acuna is going back toward the corner it
is gone
another offensive field home run for jt
real mucho
and the phillies have indeed tied this
game up
it's a 4-4 ball game here in the sixth
in it and the phillies have first and
third brad miller will come on to pinch
it
and miller lines one opposite way of
base hit that'll give the phil's the
lead as torreyas will go to second base
a pinch hit rbi single
it's a 5-4 game getting laid in the ball
game anytime someone like riley comes up
i think your first thought joe is tied
up with a home run one two to riley
swung on and hit high in the air to deep
left center field launch back there to
the wall we're tied up austin reilly
with a home run here in the eighth and
it's a five five game that ball was
crushed by riley his third base end of
the night terrace has hit one long ball
already tonight base hit likely gives
the braves the lead again
and this one a bullet up the middle of
base head here comes dansby around third
he's gonna score without a throw and
atlanta's taking the lead
three-hit game for contreras two rbis
and it's six five braves in philly
one no count
broken bat little chopper to the mound
kunrod throws it into center field
streaking around is almonte and he will
score
second and third and now acuna junior
one two count
broken bad line drive base hit one run
scores here comes haredi around third
there'll be no throw
and ronald lacunae junior does exact
some revenge on kunrad a two-strike
broken bad hit it's a five-run inning
and the braves lead it nine to five
[Applause]
oh one pitch
round ball hit to third riley to second
for one ozzy the turn it is a double
play and the braves have beaten the
phillies nine to five